you don't see but you will
the reason I said no to you when you
first asked me out do you want to go to
dinner dinner with me and the six times
after that right no no no
is because I'm moving to Brazil
[Music]
when I got there there was a lake there
a lagoon
they told me not to go but
I didn't listen
she told me I had three wishes
when it falls off my wrist
those three wishes will come true
[Music]
[Laughter]
all three of your wishes will come true
[Music]
don't know why foreign
would you even know there's no sun up in
the sky
if you crossed into a fairy tale
a storm is coming there are portals in
this world
that we may never know we've trespassed
through
[Music]
everywhere
I need to know where my wife is
people don't just disappear
which
you don't see
but you will
foreign